[Music]
it's also a great pleasure for me to be
here and
to chair also the session
um
i have been a postdoc with peter and i
will say a bit more at the conference
dinner
so
the first speaker is uh jeff wu
he was a former student
of peter
quite a while ago
and perhaps inspired by peter jeff has
worked on
an extraordinary
broad spectrum of problems
and
jeffy will talk today about the new
gaussian process model please uh it's
the floor is
yours thank you
um
i think i was number 16 of peter's
student
i remember there was another celebration
i point out the jian jing he was 32 was
the power of two i believe today is at
75 um
in 1973
i came from taiwan with an undergraduate
degree
and the education background there was
mostly memorization and competition
examination
i came to berkeley
the three to four years counting the
lectureship
retransformed my scholarly outlook in my
life
i was very lucky to have learned from a
group of masters
and the last
of the group
is my teacher peter pico
okay so i've
okay so uh this work
is joined with
uh ding ding used to be my business
poster
simon mack now in the audience and his
assistant professor duke
any time i run into problems simon will
come to my rescue okay
or this way
okay so
what is science guided statistical
learning
okay so
say engineer or scientist
will give or have some idea about
scientific models
some empirical evidence mostly
experimental but sometimes observation
fuel observation like in geology and
also they know the governing mechanism
so they give the data to the data
scientists
but these data scientists before he or
she was enlightened would just do
you know all the stuff we know
learning computation algorithm data
visualization
and then send the result back
but you can see the engineer was not
very happy
the result made no scientific sense
prediction to uncertain i should point
out usually statisticians like to say
mean square error prediction but there's
another thing very important is if your
result makes no sense which is worse
this is a capital crime that's even
worse okay so now
um
well so you complain that the analysis
is disconnected
okay so i'm sorry
so now the scientists
um
used to incorporate a scientific
knowledge and they get better prediction
and better interpretation they can see
that the engineers more happy
okay
computer experiment meaning experiment
on computer since fisher's time and all
most of my career until i moved to
georgia was on physical experiment
most of the masters we know from fischer
yates finney
george box and so forth the physical
experiment agricultural chemical
engineering
say manufacturing or taguchi okay but a
lot of things are done on computer for
example the lab the aerospace
and uh
let me see the pointer yeah
okay
the aerospace and another one you say in
cosmology so a lot of computation
usually the computation would take a lot
of time okay
so now i'm using an example based on
the
the joint work my group with the
aerospace georgia tech
so this actually is uh
one part of call injector design before
combustion before ignition okay
so here you have um
i show you this i won't have time to
explain all the details
so the
these injector geometry five parameters
okay like length
width in inside the injector
and
when you inject you inject the liquid
oxygen to be mixed
with
the blue one is the
the fuel inside the injector you want to
get a good mixing a good mix will lead
to good combustion and that's very
important good combustion
otherwise you can have some problem so
there are five parameters
so this is uh based on the large eddy
simulation large eddy actually is not
the most expensive one i'll get to that
later large eddy in this case will be
one run
uh six weeks
the number is there okay
so this is very very large uh
uh computation
okay so in the
the rocket engine design we talked about
only the injector
not the rocket okay the injector itself
is 14
days per run using large eddy large
meaning large scale
small scale will be even more
complicated but i won't have time to get
into that small scale much more reliable
will take a lot of time
and for military grade has to be small
scale okay
so how to explore the 5d
design space
by simulation along because they'll be
much cheaper
sorry
this simulation is the finite element of
final volume simulation will require
about
1 000 runs
so
what one can do and even the aerospace
people actually they knew about it for a
long time before creating because in
aerospace
you know that you cannot run
prototype would take a lot of time so
ever even 30 years ago they would do
these kind of things although they
didn't use the statistical work like
creating uncertainty quantification
so
um
emulation
would be using
surrogate model there are other ways
i'll get to that later
so for example if i have three different
geometries a different shape
and i
so well they're more suppose that
different each geometry i have a few
runs it's very expensive
then i can fit
uh using kriging to fit and there's one
step we didn't explain is that
the a new geometry may be different from
the other generation so there's another
technical word mostly in aerospace
engineering how to combine holes and do
a lot of work
into a new geometry and you do
prediction okay so that's the
ah
okay now
so this is let me show you that oh
this one should have the
animation
test it okay fine so on the
other one be the expensive
simulation numerical simulation
the low one is the one we build up in
the stack of azure tech
much much faster
okay you can see they are pretty close
now there are several people i probably
referred to one in jason
whenever a studio paper we are the first
author whenever is engineering played
the first author and this is aiaa this
one
so this is actually to
using the emulation
which is much faster to emulate for a
new geometry apart from one small part
it mimics very well
i mean there has another story we have
to go to a lower aerospace but i won't
do that that how to rectify that that
can be done too again using engineering
and statistics
okay so a very brief on gaussian process
that we input
okay say in uh
d space
and we're in
uh points
that means we run in simulation
numerical simulation
and we get outputs
so using computer code we want to
predict
and quantify uncertainty on a new code
evaluation new one we denote that x new
okay so what we do and this is standard
one at this moment
that we assign to ff is unknown a prior
stochastic process a structure
they can capture our prior belief on the
unknown function
then condition on whatever data we have
we can calculate posterior and they will
give us a lot of things
okay
so
um
so this is a usual
uh gaussian processor with the mean
function which is expectation of f x f x
a random function
then covariance function between any two
input point x 1 x 2 call k x 1 x 2
but we also point out that we should
also
uh
look at just the variance
okay
so these have been used a lot
so this is just a review that
if i have one
datum then this is the posterior 2
3
4 and so forth
the nice thing about gpu is
different from the way numerical people
do actually the numerical
uh
in finite element in american
mathematics they done this by using
their methods
the way they
handle stochastic is not as good as in
statistics i mean
the beginning of a lot of argument
between the two communities and i was
involved too now it's accepted because
we have demonstrated
a lot of work like calibration this
though might work today it's a very
important scientific problem they cannot
handle it's an invert is a special kind
of inverse problem they cannot handle we
can handle very well because we can use
again very clever use of gaussian plus
and do that okay
so
you can predict the new point
and then you also get so this is the
formula for for the
mean function it's a standard one in
textbook
and also variance so there is a variance
and they give you the uncertainty so
that's a nice thing about
using statistical
approach to such problems which is
widespread in science and engineer
and posterior
okay so in practice
say mean function usually choose a
constant unless you have some knowledge
then you can choose the linear function
the capture trend that part is easy
for the covariance function any for this
paper we use
the 1d and we extend to height d later
using material function
and the
uh
the index mu is usually multiple or half
whatever how is most common and the
omega there's another parameter there
that can be tuned from data they would
capture
how wiggly the
the actual process is okay
so and then the new actually capture the
smoothness of the sample parts or simple
parts
then we can do high dimension using
isotropic or product form
okay so here's true story this over
georgia tech
the the isy the my stack group and the
aerospace
so for example the
earlier flow prediction from a
sophisticated gp model the one we
developed we has we use that the
aerospace people did 30 simulations
each one two weeks or two weeks so you
can imagine how long
after that
we run a gp
so that was very good
however
so the aerospace program manager
like it
but
they say it's unrealistic in terms of
physics they want something not the
large 80 simulation it's another scale
the very fine scale
so they said and this sounds ridiculous
well
if i do the high the highest fidelity
and that cannot be that you enjoy that
had to be in a military computer because
that would be a real weapon
um
the high accuracy each run is
six months
six months same with prague winnie
because one of my students uh you know
selling product to them so i heard the
same thing so that's not realistic
but here's the best the best story is
that we didn't get the grain renewed but
it's for political reason okay as usual
it's not that
we're better than the album if we did
that okay but we didn't stop here we're
thinking then from this point on it's
not question of money or grant it's we
want to
pursue intellectually something of
interest because we have all other
funding we do whatever we dream that is
the following
so
you look at these physical problems they
are other
information on f
that we have not used
if we can use this information develop a
new tool new methodology they again will
say a number of runs
for example in dynamic system you can
see this one the low boundary condition
and these are very simple dropping and
there's a monotonicity constraint
another one is a shape constraint
but we are going to get the boundary the
differential equation
okay so
um
these such information in each of the
three cases
come from scientific knowledge
here's another one this is a
beam
actually this was used in my other paper
with summoning mac
roshan and other this was more
mechanical engineering that we submitted
general mechanical design so you can see
this being refastened say on the wall
one side
so you have two variables x1 and x2
okay but when you try to model that you
can put some boundary condition why
because as you know that if the
beam becomes really tiny tiny
then the bin displacement will go to
zero right
that's on the width
on the length
sorry on i'm sorry on the length you go
to zero then but when the width the x2
it thick becomes super super thick
then i mean asymmetrical relative
speaking that displays are also zero so
so that means we have these conditions
and so if we model
the behavior of
uh well there are also material
properties i don't get into so at
different kinds
okay so
boundary conditions are often available
from scientific model or visual
consideration
so the next one is the one we work with
aerospace is
using the navier-stoke equation this
actually was in a pioneering paper
someone called pope navisto also was
well known but using navisto for the
turbulence or by pope in aia again this
was a historical paper
so um this original jobs are paper and
also an ai paper but i that's a
different talk
um
so
the these very complex pdes the navistal
equations there is a kind of
conservation or momentum of deep mass
and different things okay
so the solution is a time very time
consuming to solve
okay
and another one is say they say
viscosity
that you have
the
on the left side you have say near
zero viscosity
or on the right hand side is
incompressible
in either extreme
there is closed form solution it's not
so that will give you the boundary
condition
so so what we want to do is this
we want to integrate the boundary
condition directly kitting into the gp
process
if you do so numerically then impose the
boundary that's what numerical people do
this clumsy
and
much
uh slower okay and also it's a structure
of a problem it's not it's nice why
don't you have a gp they incorporate a
boundary condition so that's what we do
so
um
if we do that we can improve the
prediction
and the faster posterior contraction and
also more interpretation because the
model itself already incorporated
physics or part of this elite boundary
so then there's a computational
efficiency issue
theoretical properties
for today's time i would just
outline some theoretical results but
computational also is a problem it's you
know quite a long paper
okay so boundary condition
we use dilution boundary
okay
and in this case we only
the boundary so assuming the boundary
with left is zero rise one
so the foresight we only have
x one equals zero
x two equals only this side boundary not
the other side so for illustration
so here i
have to use a notation i is the index
so it's an index set of inputs with
left zeros left
boundaries so in this case the i zero is
one and two variable one variable to
both has left boundary condition
but
on the right side remember the other
side there's no boundary condition so
it's empty set
okay so how do we build the boundary gp
process
the mean is easy
so if mean function needs to satisfy the
boundary constraint that's usually very
easy to manipulate algebraically
more
challenging interesting
is we need to impose so is look here
this one
okay
the last bullet
that we know that
if there's a boundary condition that
means it's already fixed
then the variance is zero
okay so that's a constraint on
the variance but it's building it's
building okay
and then that means simple passwords et
cetera these constraints
okay so
so
now once we explain it look very simple
very simple but this is the first time
people do that okay
you put
means easy it's a variance and coverage
okay let's now use a very easy 1d and we
can extend it the material covariance
and
new equal half
newton was very easy very simple
well but you can show that actually for
some differential operator as yourself a
joint differential operator
of certain kind that
this one the marten is well-known that's
why martin is very very powerful very
useful especially when you try to model
phenomenon there is a physical one
either people using mate not the
power exponential which is
mathematically simple but doesn't have
the same physical interpretation
okay so would certify the green function
this green function
okay so now the idea is that
we can put constraints
either on left or right or both
okay then the question is once we put
these constraints
with mate can we get close form of the
kernel
the machine kernel the news is good yes
so
those are the solutions either you have
boundary on both sides first one or
boundary left boundary right
um
[Music]
and this is the shape of the boundary
okay it's very important symbol but you
need to close form
because if everything numerically so
you're going to take forever
you can see
at the end that the boundary is zero
okay
well when when we had knew this
uh more than half it's using a kernel uh
convolution basically
the kernel convolution
so from one half
to
uh three half and so forth
okay you can do high dimension too
okay so it's a close form there's a nice
thing it doesn't matter the with the
iteration is messy
is computed
can be computed
and with that convolution actually very
fast compute
now for higher dimension we can do a
product
okay so let me now do a
3d example
so the 3d example
variable 1 and 3 left boundary
uh
variable tool right boundary variable
three both left and right well you see
both set index set
okay so now let's look at the first one
this is a form explicit closed form for
the first one
second one
third one okay
so putting everything together so we saw
the build of this remember we still
subject initially prior whatever yeah my
temper these are
as the first attempt to do that it's
good enough okay you can solve many
problems
okay so we do a machinery now we have a
gaussian process the incorporated
boundary condition
we have mean function we have the
covariance
and then the nice thing is now the
posterior formula is the same because
the general kriging
the is a gp process of whatever kind you
can just compute posterior
okay so that's the nice thing about this
it sounds very simple but make it
powerful
so there's no extra computational cost
it's the same kind of formula or the
only difference is we have a new gp
are we done well almost
the
so we're going to show you demonstrate
that this does improve over no boundary
but there's another issue
that we don't have we only show briefly
that that is
uh i don't know assignment this we our
second paper or part of first paper is
look very long already that is where do
you choose points
it's very important this is choosing
point for computation like these red
dots where to choose from it's an
experimental design problem and this is
not very trivial i think we only show a
little bit of that
so
the one is a full grid design you never
do it fukuri is too large
the one that's used a lot actually these
were pioneered by numerical people not
by us called sparse
grid design
and
their idea came from numerical people
know to build
the from the low dimension the
computation to high dimension
and the reason low domain hydra had
closed from iterative formula and
they've been good at that for more than
100 years
so my group most people had to read they
booked the one small book other book
people i even ran a seminar and no
credit seminar just to know that don't
be issues
we read about four or five years ago
okay so the idea is to
uh use
smaller number point to understand the
low dimension feature this is two
dimensional but it's actually for high
dimensional okay
the air points
but the airport in a very specific way
that i would never thought of because
they know from the numerical side if i
add point is whatever being done will be
incorporated in the larger one
and not just repeat the computation okay
and then so this goes by screen
screen
okay so now i show you two theoretical
results here one is
no misspecification so here we have
d dimension t variable each variable has
at least one boundary either left or
right
and smoothness meaning the true f
function
is in the reproducing kernel hebrew
space generated by the boundary
uh kernel
okay by the boundary kernel
then in the sparse grid then we get
these
convergence ray
okay
it's pretty good but i
i don't know how much
improve over
the no boundary in the numerical yes
you this question someone will answer
for me who is in the audience so
you always get your co-author who is
younger
sharper and no detail to be there and
you say oh i don't know i'm too old and
they'll answer the question okay
next one is miss specification this is
very important because what if the true
function f is in the largest phase the
zero boundary source space of a certain
kind but important thing the order of
that is smaller than new new is the
martin function
okay so what you want to know is that
means my true function
may be
not in the reposition colonial space
this is actually more a very pessimistic
one because sobolev has a lot of
functions that are unrealistic uh to
wire but this way for us to gauge how
much ray we lose the rate of convergence
and then that's the result so you see
here because s
is smaller than mu and you do the little
algebra this is a slightly slower rate
than the previous one
the pro is quite enough is the thing
young the guy the poster he did there
it
exploits the connection mathematical
connection between the boundary gp our
boundary gp and the finite element
interpolation if you know those finite
element interpolation is an
interpolation a lot of the the formula
they use and these two the interplay
between the two in order to do that so
that's very elaborate
okay so prediction rate
um
the optimal rate in all these cases we
need to improve power of predictive
power
of course the predictive power there are
a lot contributing factor but boundary
information is key if not only a but
it's a new one it's a new one
and the other one is in the paper but
not shown here it has a quicker
posterior contraction rate with the
boundary
actually i was very excited and i told
them
uh this was actually 20 20 oh i need to
speak in the pwp conference i wanted
something more mathematical i don't do a
lot of mathematical work i want
something material and maybe beep okay i
don't know but you can decide okay and
uh and by 2021 we got but then delayed
turn it 22 and resolve even better okay
so i'm quite happy to report the results
here
okay
um so uh actually another thing we
do not say scalability is due to the
design remember i said this the sparse
grid you build the high dimensional
structure from low dimension
there's a nice thing about so you do
need for this work for a lot of my work
in the last 10 years i need to know
numerical
uh mathematics and physical mathematics
for my group to in order to do this so
that's the
okay
another thing
also is i think uh
ding yang already got a result
it's at least amazing posterior
distribution response grid only sparse
grip not general
can be computed in linear time
and the reason is again is the
structural sparse grid low to high but
it's not it's easily set but it's not
easily done okay
so that's uh i believe i think probably
we need to go to another paper to do all
of that
okay american example until the very
first uh enough time okay with three
test function one is a very
in the corner is a corner peak
one is called product peak that means
it's a peak by taking product a
different component dimension this is
called rosenblock this field has a lot
of
testing function also in global
optimization global alternative in this
field are becoming closer and closer
closer okay and in some way i would say
they move towards us but we have
developed a lot of new tools and global
have been around for some time
okay so left is a full boundary
and this partial boundary you can see on
the
our side right okay this side not the
other side and there's no boundary we
want to see with an o without boundary
how much we gain so you can see that
no boundary is the recurve not as good
in terms of the log or the
rate of the error approximation
and
this is 10 dimension only so the partial
boundary and the full boundary do about
the same
so now we now choose three much more
complicated functions you can see the
middle one has many many peaks
and the right level is kind of very
strange okay
and
the left one is the four peaks
so now 30 dimension
and you can see that
the
full boundary
is better than the partial boundary
except for 11 i don't know why yeah
simon probably know
why another one is
we compare the standard gp without
boundary
you can see that those
you know gp processor you see this very
standard one in that you have the
uh
the confidence
interval for each point
um
but you see the error rate is very large
right the the the correct the confidence
interval very large but look at
the bottom one with the boundary gp
the boundary gp what's amazing is
uh
it fit very well and you can see
it's very tight very little
error
because
but of course this is still easier
problem than a novice equation with
boundary but it shows it's very
encouraging and very promising
so these
with the boundary can greatly reduce the
predictive uncertainty
or your conclusion
so
science guided statistical learning this
can be called studio learning it's a
learning okay if i write a graph of all
the air force i wouldn't just call gp or
whatever i have to say
uh statistical learning because then i
can get funding right if i only say gp
processing oh g people have been around
for so many years now i am going to cut
down your grain by half or something but
it's really you know learning okay every
single machine learning all the
passwords okay
so
um
the science guide is still learning is
crucial for technical modern scientific
problems limited data i only gave you
some examples we had done
a lot more
uh with my group of different people and
roshan has young group
the boundary gb provides a bayesian
model for in
degrading data with boundary information
which is science
with provable error improvement that we
are the theoretical rates
the future work would be
you see remember
we only have very specific delicious
boundary that we can do the mathematic
we need to do a broader class
and different boundary types for example
here on rectangular
but in a lot of work
so this will be something that simon mac
will do
i don't do okay thank you and
thank you very much for this nice
presentation
never be time for questions comments
maybe the others on zoom can hear you
better
uh thanks for the very nice talk uh what
are kinds of uh information science
driven information can you incorporate
into your prior other than this boundary
this boundary um
the the general pde there are a lot of
things you know
i take the standard one bundle is what
and this one way to initial condition
forcing terms
that you do the physical you have the
forcing terms
and uh if i do time varying computation
or combustion uh yeah we can
um the other type so so the field is
very wide i should say very very wide
yeah i only touch upon a specific type
of boundary
condition yeah so
and i can stand another minute if your
question and they would oh sorry
there's no
uh extreme hurry they're just preparing
for the next talk so somebody else has a
question or a comment peter
yes you said you only had two points
to fix the boundary conditions no no i
never said that n equals two the no the
two there were two two combinations was
a four that's crazy no it's not two
point three we have
a
region is zero to one
zero to one okay so rectangular region
left is zero
right okay we can change our rectangular
region on simple ones uh we can extend
easily but you're more circular we don't
know
but some of these are durable
but it's important to
so if the boundary is a left or right
for each
[Music]
yeah so uh just trying to get some
intuition here right i mean you're
putting your knowledge about boundaries
and you're incorporating into prior does
it improve your estimation throughout
well boundary is already zero right no
but i mean your function has to come
down the reason is that
the whole function
being involved by the boundary pull to
so i already demonstrated that
the
airway
is
like actually better than without
bundles
another one we didn't say here is uh
the uh posterior contraction faster
not so fast
but i yo you you had an example of the
30 and it seems like the improvement was
throughout rather than it near you know
just mine i need things as
conditions says
you have better performance you know
newer boundaries to get closer and
closer to the boundaries
and the you know protection information
uh
remember is the boundary that make the
difference so near boundary is kind of
poor yeah it is fair
good i think in view of time uh let's uh
thank first jeff again for the really
and
our next speaker he said